PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Welcome to
"Google Cloud Drawing Board,"
where we doodle our
way through the cloud.
Today's topic, What is Dataflow?
This video is divided
into chapters.
So watch the full
video or skip ahead
to any section of your choice.
Data is generated in real time
from web sites, mobile apps,
IoT devices, and
other workloads.
Capturing, processing,
and analyzing this data
is a priority for
all businesses.
But data from these
systems is not often
in the format that's
conducive for analysis
or for effective use
by downstream systems.
That's where Dataflow comes in.
Dataflow is a serverless, fast,
and cost-effective service
that supports both streaming
and batch processing.
It provides portability
with processing jobs
written using open-source
Apache Beam libraries.
And it removes
operational overhead
from your data engineering
teams by automating
the infrastructure provisioning
and cluster management.
How does Dataflow work?
In general, a data processing
pipeline involves three steps.
You read the data from
a source, transform it,
and write the data
back into a sink.
The data is read from
the source into something
called a PCollection.
The P stands for Parallel,
because a PCollection
is designed to be distributed
across multiple machines.
Then it performs one or more
operations on the PCollection,
which are called transforms.
Each time it runs a transform,
a new PCollection is created.
That's because
PCollections are immutable.
After all of the
transforms are executed,
the pipeline writes
the final PCollection
to an external sink.
Once you've created
your pipeline
using Apache Beam SDK in the
language of your choice, Java
or Python, you can use
Dataflow to deploy and execute
that pipeline, which is
called a Dataflow job.
Dataflow then assigns the
worker virtual machines
to execute the data processing.
You can customize the shapes
and size of your machines.
And if your traffic
pattern is spiky,
Dataflow autoscaling
automatically
increases or decreases the
number of worker instances
required to run your job.
Dataflow's streaming
engine separates
compute from storage and moves
parts of pipeline execution out
of the worker VMs and into
the Dataflow service backend.
This improves autoscaling
and data latency.
Now, how do you use Dataflow?
You can create
Dataflow jobs using
Cloud Console UI, gcloud command
online interface, or the API.
You have options for
creating the job.
You can use Dataflow templates,
write a SQL statement,
or use AI Platform Notebooks.
Dataflow templates
offer a collection
of prebuilt templates
with an option
to create your own custom ones.
You can then easily
share them with others
in your organization.
Dataflow SQL lets you
use your SQL skills
to develop streaming pipelines
right from the BigQuery web UI.
You can join streaming
data from Pub/Sub
with files in cloud storage
or tables in BigQuery,
write results into BigQuery, and
then build real-time dashboards
for visualization.
You can use AI Platform
Notebooks from the Dataflow
interface itself
to build and deploy
data pipelines using the
latest data science and machine
learning frameworks.
Dataflow inline monitoring lets
you directly access job metrics
to help with troubleshooting
pipelines at both
the step and the worker level.
How to secure
Dataflow pipelines?
When using Dataflow,
all the data
is encrypted at
rest and in transit.
To secure the data
processing environment,
you can turn off public
IPs to restrict access
to internal systems,
leverage VPC service
controls that help you mitigate
the risk of data exfiltration.
Additionally, you
can create a pipeline
that's protected with customer
managed encryption keys.
Now, what does it
cost to use Dataflow?
Dataflow service usage is
billed in per-second increments
on a per-job basis, depending
on streaming or batch data.
For batch data
processing, you can
utilize the flexible
resource scheduling
feature that reduces the cost
by using advanced scheduling
techniques.
Each Dataflow job uses at
least one Dataflow worker,
and the price depends on
the worker configurations.
Where to use Dataflow?
Dataflow is a great choice for
any batch or streaming data
that needs processing
and enrichment
for the downstream systems
such as analysis, machine
learning, or data warehouse.
Some examples are stream
analytics enabling
real-time business
insights; real-time AI
enabling predictive
analytics, fraud detection,
personalization; processing
streams of log data,
unlocking health insights
for your systems;
and of course, any
other data aggregation
and analysis scenario.
Want to learn more
about Dataflow?
Check out
cloud.google.com/dataflow.